you come from Tennessee yeah and you
grew up in Tennessee and in your whole
life and then you move to Los Angeles
for this transition into show business
yeah how's the transition going oh man
it's uh it's it's weird Ellie's a little
weird man
it's besides the few there's a few weird
things that have happened to me like
somebody pulled a heist on my apartment
though you your apartment got broken
into no it's a little bit more
complicated than that
essentially somebody pulled a heist and
they stole something very important to
me okay
I was at work and essentially I get a
call from the apartment managers then
hey there's a leak there's a leak we got
to come in we got to fix this leak I'm
like yeah go in go do it fixed leak do
it
it essentially at that time there was no
leak okay
the only leak was just a little slow
dribble of lives okay right and I go
home after hours thinking you know if
there's a leak I'm gonna see some sort
of evidence there's no evidence right no
evidence of leak but I was super hungry
okay I was very hungry
luckily I went to Trader Joe's the day
before got this flatbread bro shoot a
pizza with the spinach on it I know they
pay it's a great piece every good pizza
Trader Joe's makes a good piece yeah I
know it's like five bucks it's like a
steal yeah so I was all amped I was I
was jubilant about this pizza I was so
excited because I didn't have to plan
the night's meal okay everything was
good yeah I go to the freezer I open the
freezer the pizza is gone I understand
someone stole my freaking frozen pizza
at my home but wait a minute you're
alleging that they faked a leak in your
apartment
just steal a frozen pizza that's not
true that didn't have I swear on my life
I hope and you are dead no that's not no
they're not like he's got a frozen pizza
who cares no no it's from Trader Joe's
they're impossible to come by yeah good
pizza but look you've got them lowering
like Tom Cruise in Mission Impossible
inches from the lasers that protect your
pizza yo somebody pulled some sort of
Italian job on this freakin pizza I
swear to god you've cracked la pretty
much this is what it's like here I'm so
at anytime you're you leave your
apartment and there's a leak it's
because you're trying to get your $19
pizza what is it five five five it's a
good pizza where you getting them four
five Trader Joe's my Trader Joe's is
ripping me
you